Вітаю! Я Ольга Дудар!
Вчителька, викладачка, історик.
І сьогодні ми з вами поговоримо
про дуже відомого політичного діяча
часів Давнього Риму, про Юлія Цезаря.
Мене особистість Юлія
Цезаря цікавить дуже давно.
Коли ще я навчалась в школі, існувала
така думка, і це передавалось серед учнів,
що Юлій Цезар був геніальний, тому що
він міг одночасно робити декілька справ.
От він сідав за стіл, він міг писати,
заглядати в книгу і щось запам’ятовувати,
і коли до нього підходив, наприклад,
якийсь чиновник чи його воїн з
його оточення і йому щось говорив,
Цезар міг давати відповідь про справи,
не пов’язані ні з тим, що він
писав, ні з тим, що він читав,
тому людина, яка займа’ється
одночасно кількома справами,
часто говорять, що ти, як Цезар.
Але питання в тому, чи буде це успішним.
Про Юлія Цезаря є дуже багато історій,
і сьогодні я частково поділюся з вами
тим найцікавішим, що я
прочитала в історичних джерелах.
Але не можна працювати з історією,
не повторюючи попередній матеріал.
Тому ми з вами повернемось
відносно в недалеке минуле,
коли я пропонувала
вам зробити інфографіку
і, таким чином, для себе
створити більш стрункі уявлення
чи більш стрункий порядок,
що відбувалось в житті Римської
держави в II-I століттях до нашої ери.
І я теж пропрацювала свою інфографіку,
я зробила її, напевно, трошки кращою,
більш правильною, тому що інфографіка
— це менше підписів, а більше зображень.
Отже, давайте поміркуємо, пригадаємо,
які події відображені на схемі.
Отже, хто ці двоє діячів,
які були активні протягом
133-121 років до нашої ери?
Я сподіваюсь, ви пам’ятаєте,
це брати Гракхі, Гай і Тіберій,
які боролися за перерозподіл
землі в Римській республіці,
за підтримку бідних, за права плебеїв,
за надання фінансової
підтримки бідноті Риму;
і вони обидва закінчили життя трагічно,
але ті закони, які вони
ініціювали, які були прийняті,
ще працювали надалі і полегшували
життя бідним громадянам Риму.
Ось це зображення римського воїна і
час вказують нам на реформи Гая Марія.
Я хочу нагадати, що
він реформував військо.
Римська держава з його ініціативи
почала платити платню
військовим, тим, хто служив в армії.
Ветеранів наділяли землею, римська
армія стала дисциплінованішою,
мобільнішою, боєздатнішою, і це
для Риму було величезний плюс.
Далі таке слово як проскрипції, і
я закликаю вас його запам’ятати,
тому що, забіжу наперед,
зроблю такий спойлер —
на наступному занятті
ми його знову пригадаємо.
Проскрипції — це списки тих громадян,
які оголошувались поза законом,
їх могли скарати на смерть і всі їх
статки, майно держава забирала собі.
Цей короткий кривавий період
правління диктатора Сулли
і запровадження таких
величезних проскрипційних списків,
це наступна по хронології подія.
Сподіваюся, ви зробили інфографіку
якісніше, ви не пропустили, так як я,
першу громадянську війну
між сином Гая Марія і Суллою,
ви обов’язково включили
повстання Спартака,
і ви обов’язково включили
триумвірат і другу громадянську війну,
всі ці події, насправді, сприяли тому,
що до влади в Римі прийшов Цезар.
Виснажені всім цим
громадяни хотіли стабільності.
Ще раз наголошую, що такі види роботи
дозволяють нам краще та ефективніше
акцентувати свою увагу
на найважливіших подіях,
на найважливіших історичних діячах.
Тепер давайте проаналізуємо зображення.
Як ви думаєте, хто перед вами?
Я, звичайно, знаю, що це римські
гладіатори. Як ми це можимо зрозуміти?
Через те, що в них в руках
різна зброя, з якою гладіатори,
і тут є підписи, оскільки на арені,
де були гладіаторські бої, кожен
з них виконував свої функції.
Це, насправді, дуже детальна
інформація, якщо вона вас цікавить,
не лінуйтесь, погугліть,
пошукайте, можливо, відео
і ви краще дізнаєтесь про
цей вид такого дозвілля в Римі,
насправді дуже жорстокого, але це
частинка культури Давнього Риму.
Чому я зацікавилась гладіаторами
і все-таки акцентую вашу
увагу на цьому зображенні?
Бо я хочу вас підвести до
подій, які загрожували Риму
і відбувалися в 74-71 роках до нашої ери.
Я сподіваюсь, що ваше логічне мислення
вас підвело плавно до
тої події, яку я вже назвала.
Найбільше повстання, воно було третім,
до цього було ще два менших
повстання, теж неуспішних,
але масштаб повстання
Спартака був більшим.
Спартак як фігура історична
в літературі і в кінофільмах,
це просто легендарна особистість,
і це єдине повстання рабів, яке
насправді могло вплинути на долю Риму.
Є історики, які вірять, що
Спартак мав шанс зруйнувати Рим.
В принципі, це не дуже історично.
Через те, що сталось так, як сталось,
ми маємо проаналізувати
події і зробити власні висновки.
Чиє ім’я варто додати до списку?
У нас є Марк Красс і Гней Помпей.
Мені дуже хочеться, щоб ви третім
обов’язково додали Юлія Цезаря і згадали,
що це перший триумвірат — неформальна
організація, коли троє впливових діячів:
відомий полководець, найбагатший
громадянин Риму і Юлій Цезар —
теж полководець,
політик, стратег, оратор,
об’єдналися для того, аби спільним
зусиллям контролювати владу.
Хто з римських полководців сказав
дуже важливу фразу “Рубікон перейдено!?”
Звичайно, що це Юлій Цезар,
оскільки, перейшовши Рубікон,
він оголосив війну Римській республіці
і він визначився в своїй
чіткій боротьбі за владу в Римі.
Юлій Цезар, насправді,
надзвичайно цікава фігура.
Про нього є таке висловлювання, з
вашого дозволу, я трошки підгляну:
«він з дивною легковажністю
здійснював нерозумні вчинки,
з небаченою рішучістю
йшов до вершини влади,
геніальний полководець і дипломат,
хитрий політик, всесильний диктатор,
талановитий письменник, здатний,
при цьому, на щиру любов і милосердя».
Якщо у вас є бажання
дослідити історичні джерела,
я рекомендую вам прочитати
працю Плутарха “Александр і Цезар”,
де Плутарх порівнює
двох видатних полководців,
напевно, найвідоміших полководців
Стародавньої історії
елліністичної античної культури —
Александра Великого (Александра
Македонського) і Юлія Цезаря.
І ось така історія з життя
Цезаря, яку теж наводить Плутарх.
Коли Цезар був в Іспанії, яку він
мав проконтролювати, завоювати,
заспокоїти місцеві племена,
в момент відпочинку, читаючи книгу,
він раптом засмутився і заплакав.
Хочу вашу увагу звернути
на момент культури,
у римлян не вважалось чимось,
так само як і в стародавніх греків,
не вважалось для чоловіка обурливим
показувати свої ємоції на люди.
І якщо людина була засмучена,
то навіть пустити сльозу, це
показувало щирість почуттів.
Були ті, хто дотримувався інших правил,
це стоіки, це люди, які навпаки були
не емоційні, які загартовували себе,
але Цезар насправді був
здатний на щирі почуття.
І коли його оточення здивувалось,
чому полководець, воїн
(до речі, Цезаря дуже поважали
в армії за те, що він міг битися
на рівні з солдатами і до них
ставився з великою повагою;
він не застосовував жорстокі
покарання, окрім випадків дезертирства
або якихось, ще інших
дуже важливих провин,
а так розумів, що
життя солдата не легке);
так от, коли Цезаря спитали, в чому
причина його смутку, він відповів, що:
«В моєму віці Александр
Македонський вже захопив пів світу,
а я ще нічого не досяг...»
Для нього Александр Македонський,
можливо, був ідеалом саме полководця,
який добився поставленої мети і який
зміг бути рішучим, і зміг бути успішним.
Взагалі, про Цезаря є багато цікавих
моментів, теж хочу наголосити на одному.
З одного боку складається враження,
що він дуже емоційна людина,
яка підкоряється своїм почуттям.
Є ще одна історія, коли
Цезар вже був доволі відомий
і плив в справах морем,
корабель зненацька захопили пірати.
І вони вимагали від Цезаря суму
десь 20 чи 30 талантів, сума величезна.
На що Цезар з призирством сказав:
«Ви не знаєте, хто я. Я
заплачу за себе 50 талантів».
І пірати дозволили когось
відправити, щоб привести ці кошти.
З Цезарем залишилося двоє слуг,
але він абсолютно не боявся піратів,
він поводив себе так зверхньо,
що пірати змушені були підкорятися
його вимогам – не проханням, а вимогам.
Коли Цезар відпочивав, а пірати шуміли,
він направляв когось із тих, хто з
ним залишився, двоє чи троє людей,
і вони вимагали від піратів
затихнути, оскільки Цезар відпочиває.
Навіть в таких дискомфортних умовах
він проявляв себе як владна людина
і як людина дуже впевнена в собі.
Як би він не був впевнений і рішучий, то,
звичайно, він би не став диктатором Риму
і він би не здійснив тих завоювань,
які він насправді реалізував.
Отже, що зробив Цезар?
Ще раз давайте згадаємо,
цю історію ви можете знати через
художні фільми та мультфільми,
Цезар більше 8 років завойовував Галлію,
приєднав її до Римської Республіки.
Крім того, це територія біля
річки Рейн, і ще це частина Британії.
Це було дуже важко, оскільки ці території
ні галли, ні жителі узбережжя Рейну,
ні жителі Британії тогочасні не хотіли,
щоб римляни встановлювали
над ними контроль.
А римляни хотіли, оскільки
для них це нові території,
а для Цезаря це можливість
стягувати кошти з підкорених територій.
До речі, зробимо ще один
такий крок історичний –
Юлій Цезар не належав до багатої родини.
Часто для того, щоб прихильність
людей завоювати, він позичав кошти,
і на ці кошти наказував влаштовувати
свята, роздавати їжу простим людям,
в своїх промовах він завжди
захищав інтереси простих людей,
і таким чином значно
підвищив свою популярність.
Але щоб боржники просто його не знищили,
він мав бути успішним полководцем.
Захоплюючи території, він отримував з
них певні прибутки і тоді повертав борги.
І знаючи, що Цезар людина слова,
якщо він позичив, то він
обов'язково віддасть борги,
люди не боялися бути його
кредиторами, і Цезар на чужі кошти
спочатку дійсно завойовував таким
прагматичним чином народну популярність.
Він зумів розбити Гнея Помпея,
вважалося, непереможного полководця,
який точно так само, як і
Цезар, але з тими військами,
з якими він воював здобув авторитет,
його любили ветерани і
Помпея підтримував Сенат.
Оскільки Сенат розумів — Цезар,
інший, хитріший, розумніший, активніший
і він, врешті-решт, поборе
ось цих аристократів при владі.
Отже, Помпей програв Цезарю в
Іспанії, в Італії, в Греції, в Африці,
і, врешті-решт, був
убитий на території Єгипту.
Після всіх цих величезних перемог і
зусиль, Цезаря проголосили диктатором,
також війська дали йому почесний титул
імператора, це означало військову владу,
таку владу мали римські царі,
я сподіваюсь, ви
пам’ятаєте, ми обговорювали:
царський період, потім
республіка, і от завдяки Цезарю
республіканський лад було повалено
і він встановлює фактично монархію.
Римські громадяни були не проти, щоб син
Цезаря отримав владу після його смерті.
От з цим сюжетом пов'язана
дуже популярна в мистецтві,
дуже популярна в літературі
історія про царицю Клеопатру.
Є певні історичні стереотипи
і є історичні персоналії,
про яких ми маємо хибні уявлення.
Я думаю, у більшості, коли чують
Клеопатра, є образ дуже вродливої жінки,
настільки вродливої, що
вона зачаровувала всіх.
Насправді, тогочасні історики писали,
що Клеопатра не була такою вже красунею,
але вона мала блискучу
освіту, була гарною ораторкою,
розумілася на політиці
і була дуже розумною.
Сюжет її спілкування з Цезарем,
знайомство з Цезарем, такий пригодницький.
Клеопатра не могла потрапити відкрито
до палацу, в якому знаходився Цезар,
це було небезпечно для неї,
це був дуже ризикований крок,
і тоді Плутарх описує, що
вона вигадала такий прийом —
вона своєму повірникові, своєму слузі,
сказала, щоб він сів разом з нею в човен
і вони пропливли рікою. Є різні варіанти.
Що, наприклад, слуга
завернув її в мішок для білизни,
а інші говорять, що це міг бути шикарний
килим (це ж таки майбутня цариця),
і зав'язав його таким чином,
що це скидалося на тюк.
І потів він приніс його до Цезаря, опустив
і з тканини вийшла прекрасна Клеопатра,
яка не боялась Цезаря, яка була
гостра на язик, і вразила його настільки,
що він зробив її царицею
Єгипту, закохався в неї, одружився,
і Клеопатра народила сина,
якого в Єгипті називали Цезаріоном.
От він був ймовірним претендентом
на диктаторство, на трон уже в Римі,
якщо ми говоримо, за Цезаря Рим із
республіки перетворюється на імперію.
Чому імперію? Імперія —
це держава, яка має центр,
і цей центр контролює
захоплені території.
Імперією, зазвичай, править монарх,
людина, яка передає свою владу в спадок.
Цезар не був царем,
Цезаря називали диктатором.
Сподіваюсь, ви пам’ятаєте, ми говорили,
диктатор в Давньому Римі,
в республіці, це той чиновник,
якому надали надзвичайні
повноваження в умовах кризи.
До Цезаря була криза,
було дві громадянські війни,
було питання землі, дуже-дуже
багато різних моментів.
Як характеризує правління Цезаря
історичний матеріал, історичні джерела?
Цей текст вам не
обов'язково запам’ятовувати,
я хочу привести його, як приклад.
Я говорила вам про Цезаря як про
полководця, дипломата, політика,
але Цезар був дуже прагматичний.
Він розумів – після громадянської війни
держава вимагає економічного зростання,
і він планував докласти великих
зусиль для того, щоб розвивати торгівлю.
Наприклад, він хотів
повернути течію річки Тібр,
на якій розташований
місто Рим, таким чином,
щоб Тибр давав можливість
безпечно і легко кораблям і військовим,
але перш за все торговельним,
щоб купці могли одразу з моря
припливати в Рим, і це
суттєво б пожвавило економіку.
Далі, він хотів осушити
болота біля міст Помпеї та Сетії,
щоб потім з оцих земель
надати наділи бідним людям.
Навіщо? Навіщо Цезарю багатому диктатору,
людині, яка керувала державою це робити?
Він розумів, що його влада тримається
на популярності в простих людей.
Він розумів, що у аристократії
зберігається партія республіканців,
які абсолютно не
підтримують його політику,
але він як прагматична людина,
дуже раціональна людина,
розумів від ефективної економіки
залежить і його управління.
Цезар провів дуже важливі реформи.
Я спробувала ці реформи візуалізувати
за допомогою ось таких іконок.
Цезар роздавав містянам гроші, а
ветеранам землі. Навіщо роздавав кошти?
Щоб бідні жителі не
виступали проти його влади.
Ветеранам роздавав землю,
щоб ті, хто відслужили у війську,
пам’ятали його бойові звитяги,
зберігали це гарне враження
і були економічно незалежними.
Ще Юлій Цезар підтримував
колонізацію провінцій.
Якщо римляни небагаті
хотіли виїхати кудись в колонії,
він їх підтримував для
того, щоб там на місцях
вони ефективніше розвивали економіку.
Далі. Він розумів, що у нього
велетенська держава, і тому треба,
щоб чиновники працювали чітко, щоб
не було хабарів і треба їх контролювати,
тому він посилює централізацію держави,
щоб Рим ефективно управляв всіма
колоніями і контролював чиновників.
Крім того, він впорядковує
життя в провінціях.
Сам то він в свій час використав провінції
для збагачення, для повернення боргів,
і розумів, що ті, хто захопили провінцію
в ході війни, зроблять все для того,
щоб заплатити війську, для того,
щоб поповнити власну скарбницю.
Але йому то потрібні були
реально сильні і розвинені землі,
тому він цей процес
контролює. І обмежує розкоші,
щоб громадяни Риму, аристократи, ті хто
захопили ці землі, не забирали все собі.
Реформи Цезаря були дуже масштабними,
деякі з них мали символічний зміст і
прагматичну мету показати свою зверхність.
Це на мою думку, але...
Зверніть увагу, Цезар збільшив
кількість сенаторів з 300 до 900.
І до сенаторів, до яких раніше потрапляли
лише аристократи з поважних родин,
з граним життєвим досвідом, з
нібито бездоганною репутацією,
він вводить своїх прибічників, які були
зовсім не аристократичного походження.
Існує думка, що Цезар таким
чином мстився Сенату за приниження,
за те, що Сенат дав
Помпею більше повноважень,
а Цезаря змушував
покинути Галлію і скоритися.
Крім того, коли відбувалися засідання
Сенату, Цезар займав перше місце,
він задавав тон розмовам,
від нього залежало, які питання
будуть винесені на засідання Сенату.
Як диктатор Цезар мав право
скасовувати будь-які рішення
народних зборів і він їх не розпустив.
Збори мали місце, проте
ніхто в Римі не наважувався
всупереч диктатору
виступати проти його волі.
Ця реформа насправді підкреслювала,
що Цезар зберігав елементи давніх
традицій, елементи народовладдя,
але реально державою
правив одноосібно він.
Він призначав чиновників, він
збільшував-зменшував їхню кількість,
і від нього залежала розбудова держави.
Насправді, Цезар цікавився
багатьма питаннями.
Наприклад, він запровадив
правила дорожнього руху в Римі,
оскільки Рим був дуже жвавим
містом, де велась торгівля,
де проживала значна кількість людей.
Він розумів, що римським громадянам не
треба просто роздавати безкоштовний хліб,
чи допомагати з якимись побутовими
питаннями - важливо надати їм роботу.
Тому він розпочинає будівництва.
Те, що він запланував,
наприклад, театр, бібліотека,
нове місце для збору народних зборів,
він не встиг все це розпочати і завершити,
але те, що було зроблено за часів
його правління це: новий ринок (форум),
і збудовано нове приміщення
для засідання сенату.
Ще Юлій Цезар провів реформу календаря.
В Римі з календарем було
дуже складно, це важко пояснити,
я і сама не дуже розумію, як вони
проводили літочислення до цього.
Оскільки Юлій Цезар як дуже
освічена людина цікавився астрономією,
він вирішив, що треба
цей хаос впорядкувати.
Він запросив з Єгипту відомого
вченого і хотів запровадити календар
за зразком того календаря, за
яким послуговувалися в Єгипті.
Що було зроблено?
Нормальний рік — це 365 днів,
і раз на чотири роки рік
збільшувався — 366 днів.
Цей календар отримав назву на
честь Юлія Цезаря — Юліанський.
І ви маєте запам’ятати, що
Юліанський календар в Україні сучасній
протримався до 1917 року
і різниця набігла в 13 днів.
Тому в нашій державі є таке дивне
свято, яке ми називаємо Старий Новий рік.
Це через те, що наші
предки святкували його,
і історії недавно зовсім в інший
день. І ось така традиція збереглась.
Проте Рим не весь був підкорений Цезарю,
і не всі вважали його дії правильними.
Серед опозиціонерів, серед республіканців
в Римі виділялись двоє — Брут і Кассій.
Вони організували вбивство Юлія Цезаря.
Коли Цезар завітав на
збори, на нього напали,
нанесли йому велику кількість поранень.
Коли він побачив серед нападників
Брута, до якого він дуже гарно ставився,
і напевно, щось було на
зразок “як батько до сина”.
Брут молодший, Брут
освічений і дуже розумний,
він говорить свою останню
фразу: “І ти, Брут...”.
Смерть Цезаря стала
для людей потрясінням,
люди не вірили, що такого всесильного
диктатора можна так просто знищити,
і ставлення до цього розділилось.
Прихильники Цезаря теж були
сильними і його смерть, насправді,
не принесла республіканцям
бажаної перемоги,
вона просто повернула
Рим до моменту боротьби
між двома сильними угруповуванням.
Але це вже матеріал
нашого наступного уроку,
коли ми будемо говорити
про наступника Юлія Цезаря,
про людину, яка змогла
реалізувати плани Цезаря,
і для якої Цезар насправді був взірцем.
Перш ніж ми завершимо наше заняття,
я попрошу вас вдома,
коли ви прослухали урок,
відкрити підручник обов'язково,
прочитати про Юлія Цезаря
і скласти його історичний портрет.
Давайте разом пригадаємо за яким планом.
Цей план не є обов'язковим.
Ви можете змінити щось, додати, залежно,
скільки часу ви вирішили витратити,
наскільки вас захоплює
особистість Цезаря.
Тому дуже важливо знати про
дитинство, освіту та виховання,
про те, як сформувалась
особистість видатного діяча.
Чи знаємо ми який був ззовні вигляд
Цезаря, яким був його характер?
Це теж дуже важлива риса,
оскільки Цезаря обожнювали,
і деякі його скульптурні портрети
насправді художньо перебільшені.
Скульптори робили його тіло ідеальним,
а от обличчя уже створювали
близьким до реального обличчя Цезаря.
Нам важливо схарактеризувати
його політичну діяльність і я визначила
не всі його реформи, я звертала
увагу на ті, які, напевно, є найважливіші.
Проте ви можете пошукати і додати
цікаві моменти про його діяльність.
Нам важливі свідчення сучасників
і висновки сучасних істориків.
Чому? Ті люди, які бачили Цезаря
вони описували події під враженням,
Цезар був дуже харизматичний,
і відповідно ті, з ким він спілкувався
потрапляли під його вплив.
Сучасні історики порівнюють різні
історичні джерела, роблять свої висновки,
тому порівняння історичних джерел і
історичних досліджень це теж цікава тема.
Я сподіваюсь, що надихнула вас
дослідити особистість Юлія Цезаря,
що ви запам’ятаєте найважливіші
матеріали, і це нам дозволить
на наступному уроці ефективніше
поговорити про Римську імперію.
Дякую вам за увагу, і до нового уроку.